hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
hey gang it's your old pals uncle Hank
and Kippy Kevin James Ryan special
announcement the ru garbage patreon is
alive oh baby it is up and running clean
living go to patreon.com/scishow every
week we're gonna have stuff me and Foley
from the hard feelings archive we're
gonna do live streams the whole nine
yards
get in while you can buy low sell high
what they say so check it out everybody
go to patreon.com/scishow are you
garbage we need this welcome to another
exciting edition of ru garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is our you
garbage the show where we sit down with
your favorite comedians and find out if
they grew up classy or if they grew up
absolute trash I'm your host H Foley
coming at you from my mom's man cave
down here in southeastern Pennsylvania
word on the street pork chops on the
smoker for Dindin and I cannot be
happier
my co-host coming at you from an
undisclosed location somewhere southern
New Jersey Wildwood 222 Ocean Avenue our
good pal Kippy Kevin James Ryan
everybody yo-yo king of the boardwalk
still reigning supreme down here dude
Sam's pizzas as the eye can see and I'm
loving every [ __ ] minute of it I'm
happy to be here guys thanks so much for
tuning in if you're new to the podcast
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube you can subscribe there as
well and if you are new check out our
past episodes we had [ __ ] mark
Normand and sodor joel is Bobby Kelly
[ __ ] Andrew Schultz we had [ __ ]
everybody so go check those out guys and
hit that patreon baby are you garbage
Triana backs laughs are you garbage get
on there for all kinds of exclusive
content it's gonna be fun
but that's neither here nor there we are
extremely excited about our very funny
guest today he is an extremely funny
stand-up comedian he tours all over the
country he makes regular appearances on
the bonfire on Sirius XM with big Jay
oakerson and Dan Soder he's also a
regular on the Doug Stanhope podcast he
was a 2019 selection for jfl new faces
of Montreal Canada he's in the extremely
funny short tires and he's also as a
director of totally tiny teen short bad
deal but the big question on everybody's
mind today is he garbage but blow is the
what was the bad deal bad deal you
didn't direct that 20-19 not on your
imbd no this guy fake fake I am D
credits Jesus Christ that's all in there
it says you're a writer and director of
it yeah I think that might be a
different guy it was your picture
Shane Gillis what's up you forgot a
couple credits but how's it going hit
what did he forget cast not to know I
don't give a [ __ ] are you garbage
situation I honestly up until probably
twelve hours ago I would have said
complete garbage but I did a little
research till homework I'm gonna say the
kids all class Skippy what are you
thinking I don't know man I know he's
got you know he's got your family
Harrisburg or something right I'm
leaning garbage that's tough you're from
like Central PA a little bit
I'm from mechanicsburg so yep but I grew
up in like a nice nice house and a nice
neighborhood how far away were you from
Harrisburg it's like 20 minutes west the
same comparison to where we are to
Philly so the
but definitely rural right blue-collar
yeah yeah well it's weird how much this
area has changed in the last like 10
years I mean it was definitely very
rural and very blue-collar but now it's
totally suburban it's not mean American
and we were one of the first suburban
neighborhoods out here so I've always
been it's always a good look when you
have it's new money I like it I first
the first new development the first
cul-de-sac in the we [ __ ] gentrified
real estate started going up we're not
doing too bad well he grew up on like a
creek eight siblings and they all fist
fought and their dad died they were they
were garbage that's like real garbage
but the thing is is that kind of never
really good like my kids hopefully will
have zero garbage I'm half sure so this
is this is what we're finding out about
it's like it's generational you know
what I mean like if your dad was garbage
your garbage your kids might even be
unless unless you have like an all-star
career they're gonna be somewhat [ __ ]
garbage yeah I have this thing where I'm
starting to do I do a lot of the stuff
that my dad's I wasn't like I'm starting
to like just like the mannerisms are
like Oh everything yeah so that led that
that that inherent garbage doesn't
really go away too easily I gotta say I
saw an Instagram story of you your dad's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] brick [ __ ]
he's the rest right that's that's been
the debate lately in fact dude that is
such I do with my days such a trash
thing if you're like I could take it
he's like I got one more left in me kid
I was a hundred percent what he says I
was gonna ask you I was gonna ask you as
a question and it was gonna be a trick
question like whether you thought you
could beat your dad up and the trick
question is is even think about that
you're [ __ ] trash cuz intelligent
classy people don't think about it
literally before this podcast started he
and I had that debate in the kitchen
today and he cuz I you know I squared up
to him in like jab him a little and
joking around yeah of course
and he was like I'll [ __ ] you up and I
was like I would beat the [ __ ] out of
you and this was in front of my mother
so she backs your dad up she backs your
old man up like a [ __ ] ash oh he's
done that so one time I came out of the
bathroom and my dad [ __ ] towel
whipped me in the face okay oh he was
doing laundry which is right it was
insane he towered me in the face and
then I [ __ ] grabbed the towel and he
hid behind my mother and I was like I
was like you've Joan you better move or
I'm gonna [ __ ] tell with you stayed
still so I towel waved her and normally
I'm bad at towel with it but I [ __ ]
it was a perfect crack and she and my
dad went from like all this is playful
to just in my [ __ ] face like he hit
his girl yeah you got my face it was
just like I'll [ __ ] you up you [ __ ]
my dad's call me a [ __ ] so many times
crazy yeah there's a trashy family's
there's a ten-year period with it where
the Sun and the dad are just that like a
constant [ __ ] standoff because once
they get into their 60s they start
losing a little bit more but from like
from 50 to 60 it's just too too [ __ ]
lions are in each other out anything I
got when I was I was playing football so
I got very big and I would I just would
bully this [ __ ] guy like he was he
was probably like 50 years old and I was
no no no and [ __ ] like college and
football so I would like wrestle him and
beat his that but if we fist fought back
then he would have [ __ ] me up yeah
it's a weird thing there's some kind of
psychology or like yeah like even at
like you know like I put football to not
like my prime physical shape I was still
like you know not scared but like I knew
there's something about a man's like a
grown man's hand punch it in the face
that just does so much damage and just
even though they're out of shape they
have that look in their eye like yeah
well they'll do it get you and they're
they're different that's the
that's the generational thing where my
dad grew up fighting constantly I've
been in like ten fights this guy used to
fight constantly yeah so he's I mean
from the time here we're like
neighborhoods used to fight you know I
mean let's go to the third Street and
just [ __ ] those guys up you're like what
just fightin dudes from his section of
the place Irish and Italians going at it
we're [ __ ] with each other at the
playground
yeah man out here it was uh it was the
anti Catholics we still had the real
yeah we in in Mechanicsburg we still had
good racism where it was just Northern
Ireland [ __ ] yeah my dad but as the
story values playing basketball one day
and he went to the same high school as
me we went to a Catholic High School and
there's a school called red land here
which is like I don't know they
literally do even when I was in high
school their student section would wear
orange when they played us to like the
Protestants and they [ __ ] very my
game my dad was and they threw like fish
onto the court to the king
that's like 1800s yeah that's gay I'll
stop hijacking your [ __ ] pockets but
a good smile that was no that's what
dude that's what they want baby we won
this game in this game my dad gripped up
the dude he was guarding it was like if
I see you outside of this I'm gonna [ __ ]
you up and like four years later in
college he saw the guy to bar I don't
think the guy recognized him and my dad
was like outside he [ __ ] out of a guy
for no reason you fast forward like 30
years the guys eaten dinner with his
family at some casual dining you guys
are in there eating you guys think I'll
be right back at the check that's like
the last scene in sleepers when they
kill [ __ ] Kevin Bacon ya know what is
your pop do what does he do for a living
he's a Salesman so okay he does I was
actually making fun of him yesterday he
also protect like all dads he thinks he
was a [ __ ] troupe for some reason in
his old age he you know he like salutes
the flag and [ __ ] and now he's just a
Salesman it's not sound short but yeah
I'm down in Wildwood and every Friday
and Saturday and Sunday morning on the
boardwalk it shuts down at 10:00 a.m.
and they play the pledge of allegiance
and the national anthem dude and it is
it's pure America dude I loved every
second of it I'm sitting there like
Trump 2020 baby this is good it's me
nationalism you get you guys some white
dudes going on nationalism it's hard to
pump those brakes once that blood gets
pumping dude it's [ __ ] you what guys
love that we did we did taps on Memorial
Day at 3 o'clock made everybody stop at
the party the kids that taps play for
somebody my neighborhood somebody in my
neighborhood I guess has a trumpet and
they played taps on Memorial Day and my
dad stood up and he literally stood
there like that and we were like that
was that was what started the troop
fight I was like your [ __ ] salesman
stop your dad's paying for a flyby over
the house was mine what about your mom
what does she do for a living she was a
teacher I think she's retired now okay
that's pretty good all right and typical
growing up how was that uh it was good I
mean trouble yeah you getting the
trouble as a kid I did get a lot of
trouble but it was never real trouble it
was never like yeah I wasn't doing
[ __ ] just kidding yeah I guess we
were like smoking cigarettes and weed
and [ __ ] but you know you weren't like
stealing cars in Harrisburg no nothing
like that
just drank just substances that was
always the problem there you go cuz
Harris pretty scary man I've only I've
only been there like [ __ ] wrong where
I realize it like I've only been there
remembering it once for a show earlier
in comedy it was Labor Day weekend that
I think the place where you started was
probably here yeah
H Mac hvac that huge that huge big big
stage right yeah it was yeah it was like
me Kevin cotton and Jonah
Shaner murdered everybody knows [ __ ]
bomb Shaner ate my lunch to the point
where like his setups were like getting
some applause
yeah Junior's shaders bill for h-back
he's like
cuz it's all like [ __ ] white trash
that think they're hipsters yeah stand
up and bring him back
here's something I want to bring up
before we go into the questions we hand
the questions a second play are you
garbage this is something interesting I
don't know if Kitty knows this but am i
right or wrong and hearing the fact that
you got into West Point is that right
yeah I did did you do that's how what
were your grades in high school uh they
were good but not like I mean honestly
it's pretty crazy I think I was ranked
like bottom of my class that's a good
school yeah I did well on the SATs and
also not like great I got like an eleven
seventy it wasn't crazy but I got a
twice what I got but I got uh it was for
football that's how I got it but did you
get the appointment from my things you
have to get it by a congressman yeah I
met like with a congressman who tried to
like I mean they were all excited to put
ball player was going cuz normally
truthfully the guys that go to West
Point typically are [ __ ] dorks super
smart yeah it's a lot of soccer players
in cross country dudes a lot of Boy
Scouts it's mostly literally Boy Scouts
like most [ __ ] dudes at West Point
where Eagle Scouts it's [ __ ] crazy
but a lot of them had like perfect SATs
it was nuts
then yours in there [ __ ] giving kids
Huggies and shoving them in well I got I
quit like right away I play that what
are you actually yeah I quit after three
weeks oh [ __ ] I didn't know that you
actually went there and did all that
yeah
I didn't know you were allowed to do
that you just quit the army after three
weeks yeah well once I heard you could
just leave I was like I well I'm gonna
[ __ ] leave five years now if you quit
I think after your sophomore year you
owe them the the service so dudes that
like with their junior senior year just
our enlisted as privates
brutal yeah it was just I you know I was
a [ __ ] and I [ __ ] up going there so
it was like like day one I was [ __ ]
around like joking and a drill sergeant
heard me so he heard somebody so he
comes running over to us it was like who
said that and a [ __ ] dude next to me
stepped up and told on what that's for
see [ __ ] yeah man yeah I had a smidgen
over there trying to hold each other
accountable yeah these are my kind of
guys yeah go back to mechanicsburg and
fight my dad well he was he was through
the [ __ ] roof one day he's a football
army that was like he was there's still
army hats in my house floating around
like there's still West Point gear
around the house uh he I remember one
day I was leaving the house and I was
talking to him about going to West Point
because I didn't really want to go but
there was a lot of pressure my parent
like I told my mom I was gonna commit to
temple and she cried I almost went there
and quit definitely after two-a-days
first year I would have quit yeah it was
down to Eastern Michigan temple and army
well what year did you graduate high
school
oh six oh yeah I was on fine they were
terrible when you when you would have
went there yeah that's why I got offered
Haworth dude they would lose games like
[ __ ] 6500 and the night before that
were you showing up in my house on like
a Friday night for like a kegger I'm
like dude but uh is that what you did
you quit that's a football yeah I quit
cuz it definitely [ __ ] sucked and I I
was definitely like soft and as soon as
I found out I could quit I was like oh
I'm [ __ ] out of here yeah going into
it my dad was definitely pissed at first
so the the West Point like trains the
parents cuz they know during basic
training every kid is gonna be like I'm
out I'm going home and so when I show
the parents are trained to be like
you're not allowed to come home you're
not allowed in our house so my parents
said that to me and I was like you
[ __ ] losers cuz it was all letter
correspondence too so I like wrote to me
yeah I got a letter that was like you
can't you can't quit so that I wrote
like a [ __ ] three-page on loosely
shitty handwriting just like you never
did [ __ ] with your lives don't tell me
to [ __ ] do this
and a horse I regretted it I was being a
[ __ ] I was being emotional and I felt
you know I felt horrible about writing
that letter but yeah and soon and then
the next letter was like sorry we were
told to do that you can obviously good I
can't imagine the anxiety involved in
[ __ ] having to send a letter like
that with all those emotions in it then
wait for [ __ ] two weeks for it yeah
then you gotta wait til Tuesday for
[ __ ] mail call till Sean shows up oh
yeah you got a mail call was [ __ ]
hilarious too now the the basic training
stuff was kind of easy at West Point
like it's designed for like I said dorks
to get cross country people it's not
like Murray yeah it's not like Marines
or army boot camp it's [ __ ] it's like
do ten push-ups like the drill start the
drill instructor has gotten in trouble
for swearing at us like yeah like cadets
reported the drill instructors for using
profanity and they got drunk and then
they came back from that meeting and
we're like you [ __ ] [ __ ] here we go
Jesus [ __ ] it so that's the whole
[ __ ] that like it's all it's all
about like duty honor country that's the
[ __ ] thing so like if somebody cheats
there's an honor code like if if you're
cheating or something it's everybody's
duty to [ __ ] tell on you know I get
that cheating is one thing but [ __ ]
ratna yeah what about the [ __ ] yeah
the code that you for your fellow
soldiers did these [ __ ] guys see a
few good men it's the first pitch
keep your mouth shut go drag himself yes
it was a tough one it was a dark period
Wow
it's all working out baby almost close
dude I was gonna channel my god kids
having a girl kids having a great two
years old man this is really gonna
[ __ ] hot and wait that was a double
that was a double pump - your old man -
cuz first he had West Point and was he
excited about that - uh well truthfully
they had 24 hours to be excited about
SNL no yeah I mean they had 24 hours so
thankfully it wasn't like they didn't go
around bragging really to their friends
as much as they would have if they had
more than 24 hours he's got a [ __ ]
hate you man - new in the kitchen one
day I know did they take me from reasons
to brag at the bar yeah he just shows up
in people like how's your son hey Gilles
what happened to your boy over there
real [ __ ] fishy - that kid huh real
funny guy all right let's play are you
garbage that was awesome man I love that
we're gonna ask you a series of
questions shame determine whether you're
garbage or not like I said you got the
West Point thing was big with me even
even if it was athletic I'm all and I
got [ __ ] I got 700 on my SATs the kid
struggles the kids struggles are you
dumb
you don't seem dumb no I am yeah dude
Foley's dumb in every everything
socially well I don't agree you're funny
how are you dumb what [ __ ] phrase no
yes dude he's doing Rodney Dangerfield
if you really boil it he's just doing
Rodney you want to know how my school I
get more respect that's what I
no I was terrible to take intestine all
that stuff I was be a bad student 11:50
you're [ __ ] Kennedy in my book well
let's find out Kippy you want to start
it off you want me to hit him with a
couple of a couple of the basics yeah
you can do a couple of the basics yeah
I'm interested to know shampoo in the
bathroom what were you working with down
there I imagine it was Irish Spring your
old man Jesus yeah it depended who Italy
depended on who went shopping grocery
shopping no I had two older sisters so I
did have some nice stuff
my two older sisters so there was but it
was [ __ ] I didn't know what the [ __ ] it
was it was always like you know I have
to read bottles to figure out today I'm
at home I might I was embarrassed to
report this yesterday there's a box of
tissues in the room I'm staying in that
I used up I don't know what the [ __ ]
she's doing in my room but second
secondly that's a tough law dark one she
knows what's going on yeah it's no good
she knows what's going down always
thought I was getting away with it to
not not recently but in like seventh
grade I would shower for like an hour
and a half
sure in my head I've never been caught
like I've never been fronted so I think
I got confronted probably two years
later when I was out my sisters my
sisters were quick to be like yeah
everybody knows you're beaten off in the
shower knock that off well we just had
we just had a situation with the kids
apparently last summer it started but
the three boys a couple of nephews and
some cousins we're doing the [ __ ]
take to turn on the Jets by the pool
[Laughter]
what he's doing that's my jet go into
your [ __ ] jacuzzi no yeah they were
[ __ ] taking turns on that [ __ ] my
mom had to put the kibosh on take turns
putting their [ __ ] stinger in the
hole on you boys hurry up over there
holy [ __ ] so stuff with yours good stuff
with your sisters that's pretty good
will you a Miracle Whip room or a
Hellmann's mayonnaise family I don't
know I was neither
I guess mayonnaise are you a no
mayonnaise guy I've grown into it wha
grown up now never yeah it's a pretty
classy thing cuz I love it I know that's
[ __ ] garbage if you don't like
mayonnaise you're okay in my book
because you're a little bit of a classy
individual cuz I'm trash I love it you
was you said it was like a nicer house
single family home
I presume yeah yeah did you have a
garage yes we have a two-car garage
Oh alright I have a two-part question
could you park two cars and that garage
er was a filled with [ __ ] the garage you
can't park one car in it what's in there
well like a boat in there that doesn't
run a couple of junkies or something my
sister that got addicted to heroin has
all her stuff in there
he lives here yeah the whole thing's
filled with like three different three
different failed ventures to live by
themselves it's it's a it's it's a shell
of a nice house that's exactly that's
say I grew up the same exact way I'm
snow should did you have a refrigerator
in that garage
there was a freezer oh now there's
nothing now that there is a refrigerator
down in the back room here in the
basement that for real [ __ ] it's got
to be 25 years old of course
yeah and it's guy it still works and
there's there's a Milwaukee's Best Inn
there that's been there since I was in
high school high school no one has
touched natty light in mind literally
from ice I might I might go get it and
look at it [ __ ] chug that I wonder
whether to get for real it must have
expired in like oh three does beer go
bad yeah there's definitely a big after
like a decade for sure yeah so no garage
fridge no no fridge with lettuce wraps
yeah it was a big freezer yeah yeah
what's in there what meat and stuff it
was now there's nothing now there's
nothing she's got cancer now so laugh it
up yeah yeah yeah cool no it's a [ __ ] it
it's actually it's working out for you
get you get more sympathy for cancer
than heroin oh we make sense yeah it's a
lot more loving the hunting Phil my dad
hunted I never did
okay very good yeah fishing I like
fishing I suck at it but yeah it was
always like bait a lot of bait and [ __ ]
in the fridge but he gave up on that he
wasn't he wasn't an outdoorsman either
did he have a Nightcrawler guy for a
little while somebody I just got some
night crawlers I was down in Virginia
fishing and night crawlers are [ __ ]
terrible that suck to use as bait you
gotta [ __ ] they're huge and you gotta
like hardcore them still and just go and
they obviously they don't like the hook
they're like yeah yeah it's not fun you
know you're hurting these [ __ ] one of
us ain't coming back just for me to
catch a fish that I don't even want to
catch just for me to cuz then I could
catch a fish and I feel bad for that - I
got a rip a hook out of its throat
mm-hmm yeah yeah it's not worth it do
you have do you have other family that
live in the area like cousins and all
that kind of stuff like around the area
yeah though they a lot of them have made
the jump to Florida and not and not like
nice oh my god not really reach now the
Cocoa Beach ranch houses in Florida
ain't no coming back from that dude you
don't you don't you don't go back up a
level go and they're all raging
alcoholics
there you go is it my aunt that lives
down there now one one year at Christmas
so this gives you a good idea in the
family cuz they they all did pretty well
financially but my uncle is a hard-ass
and he stood up and was like this is a
middle of Christmas this guy just stands
up and it's like holds up a drink we're
about to open gifts and he holds up a
drink he's like to all the Gillis's that
couldn't be here no oh yeah cheers and
then my dad my dad stood up and held up
a drink it was liked all the women in
the surface my aunt who was sitting on
like a tall chair with her feet kind of
hooked into the bar just fell and
saluted the troops and then my aunt
passed out at 11:00
4head my other uncle yelled out cuz
everybody got quiet for a second my
uncle yeah it's like somebody get that
woman a drink but Mayhem's just a bottle
of Jack Daniels flying through your eyes
oh the reason the reason I ask is
because I wanted to know when you were a
kid and you guys would like go on like
little trips with the family have you
ever taken a trip with your family that
required multiple vehicles where you
followed each other like followed each
other to Knoebels Grove
yes I'm [ __ ] like that yeah yeah yeah
for sure cuz we would always go with my
cousins and [ __ ]
so yeah always multiple multiple fans of
kids that's a real trash just a caravan
garbage don't have to do that now
because you got the GPS but I remember
[ __ ] like three and four cars like
drive into some [ __ ] Zoo so none of
them were Maseratis I'll tell you that
they were all like [ __ ] station is a
green mercury van I remember it green
like a dark green van this was one since
you're from the area till did we play
with the people from the air did you
ever go to Busch Gardens uh yeah but the
one in Virginia is Colonial Williamsburg
my friend I went to Colonial
Williamsburg on a fifth grade field trip
the school's not too bad yeah that's
pretty but no I went to push cart we're
I was more of a Gettysburg guy used to
go down to Gettysburg a lot that was
that's one of my next questions did you
ever go to Gettysburg reenactment bro I
loved Gettysburg reenact I was I was
watching grant last night on the History
Channel that [ __ ] rules yeah it's pretty
good no I've loved the Civil War for I
mean I I would go to Gettysburg like if
I needed time to reflect
I still do that like I'll Drive to
Gettysburg by myself and like stare at a
battlefield to be like yeah alright my
girlfriend you know is living with a
different guy that's fine yeah feels
like more Michael said maybe
yes actually like the week the week of
the SNL thing me and O'Connor where it
went out of Gettysburg just [ __ ] I
got in trouble they tried some lady
tried to like get me in trouble for that
cuz we made fun of Gettysburg on the
podcast
the most recent podcasts before I got
cancelled and it was like we're calling
the Confederate soldiers [ __ ] gay and
talk about how Connecticut only sent
down like sweet boys for the past I
doubt a transcript about it was like he
doesn't respect the Civil War and
everyone was like that's actually funny
this Confederates definitely misguided
at a family party you guys serve Jaeger
probably when it was popular there was
always people but like I said everybody
was his alcoholics now and they had
every people had to stop drinking okay
so now they're trying some of them are
still just going yes [ __ ] it and so yeah
they I don't know I unfortunately I had
to the last couple years I haven't gone
to the [ __ ] family Christmas party
because of the [ __ ] career yeah yeah
I've been working Jaeger was definitely
there for sure so they went through the
cycles of all that my family till yeah
they were [ __ ] trash okay bye sweet
tea vodka instead of mixing it with like
lemonade they mix it with vodka they do
that and Tina's together like [ __ ]
animals [ __ ] trash Hey Jesus Christ
is there currently a car parked on your
lawn that works or doesn't work no no no
okay okay
have you ever do that have you ever
owned a sports team Hat or Jersey that
had camouflage on it yes
what was it I think I had a camo Eagles
hat like this year I lost it lost it at
a restaurant yeah actually you know it
wasn't camo is one of those [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] uh what's it called like workers
hat what the [ __ ] is the Carhartt yeah
it was a good car hardy go sad it's
pretty sick yeah I'm gonna go no one do
you own anything with the true camo
technology yes I have a sheets
long-sleeve camera it's sheets camo is
[ __ ] sick and I also took this is
funny I took a picture like in a mirror
like acting like I was taking a very
serious selfie wearing it obviously
anybody that knows we know it was a joke
but when I cancelled that was really
paint was like all I remember look I
remember looking over to Mike Mike my
wife I think I'm like I'm like they're
really [ __ ] doing I'm dirty
are you doing you any favors hey do you
know that guy I never met him anywhere
in your house is there a half a bottle
of windshield wiper fluid yeah for every
girl
yeah yeah there's actually also like 50
cans of paint for some reason my god
useless cans of paint why don't we throw
it out I don't understand you never know
it was crazy they go back like five
years later like oh we still got some
paint in the garage she's hard and
separated from the previous homeowner
it's not even you did yeah okay have you
ever ridden a golf cart not on a golf
course uh yeah probably all right
sometimes like sometimes an uncle has
Wanda like drive to go get the mail
ya know you know we used to steal some
golf carts on that yeah but now that was
always out of course there's there's a
lot of golf courses around here riding a
golf cart is [ __ ] clean livin I just
did it two weeks ago my friends were out
golfing I can't call for [ __ ] so I just
went out to drink gym shorts and
flip-flops
and it's great it's a caddy you're
[ __ ] nuts people get it cats gonna
caddy I'm the [ __ ] car now
up and around yeah it's crazy this is
this is so it's like here's what I'm
saying it's like a nice house but then
there's uh I can't
I turned me off on here there we go
every time I do this I look at my own
crazy but yeah it's just showed us a
drop ceiling with a [ __ ] tile moved
out of place like it was reaching for a
handgun some water damage on that one
you got a leak upstairs yeah my mom
clogged the toilet here and the the
ceiling dropped out in the basement yeah
my mom dropped one hard she shits like a
dude that's [ __ ] hilarious anyone in
your family have truck nuts hmm oh no
okay no true although I do have a cousin
that he's never not wearing gym shorts
all year-round and almost never has
sleeves like and he's used the funniest
[ __ ] dude in the world he he wore a
Purdue windbreaker
to his brother's wedding over
windbreaker
what's the wedding cash bar ah no no no
you can't
I remember my cousin wanted me to do
stand-up I've done stand-up at a wedding
it doesn't it I did it I tried to avoid
it and I got there late and I still
write when I walked in as soon as I
walked in the door they were like oh
he's here Shane why you say a few words
and all I did was make fun of my cousin
Frankie who was wearing the pullover
Edie front tooth is one he was lifting
and he dropped the weight yeah I just
made fun of his dead tooth and his mom I
was like may your love live forever like
Frankie's dead booth audibly was like
Jesus Christ she pretty great I said
like one thing I made fun of Frank
that's so we always had somebody in the
family that would show up to a wedding
[ __ ] wearing like he was wearing
khakis in a windbreaker to be honest
[ __ ] their day that family is [ __ ]
nuts
dad that's how my family is they're
probably my favorite people to hang out
with their their dad was my dad's
brother and he he [ __ ] uh he's the
smart one of the family he was the
oldest and he he like went it he went to
Notre Dame and then he afternoon Notre
Dame he volunteered and joined the
Marines in Vietnam geez and then he's
then he got out and became a prison
warden and he's a [ __ ] hard-ass but
he's funny he's very [ __ ] funny and
his kids either from like the coal
region his wife said they're from like
Shamokin and that's you want to see some
[ __ ] white trash dude gosh anywhere
in the coal region is [ __ ] it's crazy
they're all like Ukrainian and [ __ ] like
blocks from the true white trash is very
true white trash is Eastern European
yeah very Eastern European up in
Northeast Pennsylvania but those dudes
those dudes that Nam that volunteered
those guys are [ __ ] badasses
yeah he was he was yeah and then he came
back and was again he was a prison
warden and what's funny is it like
transformed him
he was around all the people he worked
with were black dudes in like the 80s so
that's how he talks now for real hundred
persons I give [ __ ] how's it
going you jab [ __ ] last time I
was with them they have a house out in
South Bend so they're always they go to
every single Notre Dame game my cousin's
here's a good one my cousins they lived
here they lived in Mechanicsburg and
they would go they would drive to every
single Notre Dame game which is like a
10 hour drive there were days where they
would leave Friday night to get there
for a you know 3:00 p.m. kickoff on
Saturday and drive back after the game
Luna that's insanity lunatics last time
I was there there eating ham salad salad
you know what it's called it's called
monkey meat that's an upstate pets of
anything really was a kid the grossest
[ __ ] I've ever seen that's on the front
rank and Coleridge ham sits like a pink
paste it's unbelievable it's chopped ham
a little bit of relish and mayo
fantastic it's like garbage pate it's
it's some of the grossest [ __ ] I've ever
seen
actually I here's a picture of my cousin
Frank also he's again he's wearing a
Purdue Purdue basketball jersey during
the day Frankie is the best there is
eating a ham salad oh look here's the
windbreaker at the wedeck what did he
say when when you [ __ ] on him like dude
you're like clearly I just saw the
picture of you you're wearing a suit and
tie and what is he what were you like
why are you in a suit and he's like this
is okay yeah of course it's academic
it's suit come on he this is a guy who
during the Christmas parties or any
party he'll lay on the couch like the
whole family will be in the room he's
just blaming cast he lays on the couch
he also
always has a jug of iced tea as a
spinner on it he's nuts you'd love him
that's too [ __ ] funny Oh Mike dude
this is better I think you're gonna say
you would carry around a jug of iced tea
to drink but the spitter is over the top
jug of ice he always has a gym bag with
him no he goes to the gym every day
strong gym bags are garbage though yeah
hey carries around a weight belt and gym
bag man old with skull he sounds like my
favorite [ __ ] guy that's awesome
he's my fave he was just telling me how
a skull doesn't kill you I was like I
was like I really need to quit dip
because I did but I was like I gotta
quit soon he's like it doesn't kill you
I'm fine makes you strong like me have
you ever paid for anything with a money
order no I don't think so that's
financial stability right there that's
not too shabby anybody does anybody you
know when you were growing up ever been
seriously injured in an ATV or mini bike
accident yeah yeah there's a bunch of
that was something that would happen a
lot around here for sure the ATVs are
[ __ ] dangerous man yeah a lot of
people out here at ATVs and shed and
kids would just get [ __ ] up on those
things have you ever rented a snowmobile
for like the yeah or not okay I have not
that's that's always a real [ __ ]
trashy thing someone who rents a
snowmobile for an hour to go in a circle
bricks no I never did that now I know
you mention it it's a it's fun but it's
like you know it's like the same people
that rent a waverunner and just like
zipper yeah do you currently have a
pocket knife no why United it no courage
do not know it's a funny question no I
don't have one now when I was a kid yeah
big it's easier to pocketknife he did
one did you never knew I was gonna pop
off shader probably still yeah no dude
we just did a podcast with him in
[ __ ] six and he like pulled out did
he pull out like a snub nosed shotgun
out of nowhere we're like what the [ __ ]
is that
yeah the shaders are [ __ ] idiot he's
the man he's a man he's the man he's my
favorite um have you ever owned a wrist
rocket uh no BB gun have not uh yeah
just got actually I just got my first
baby I probably laughs that's real fun
like when the West pulling and we're
technically on SNL you just bought a BB
gun
I got a BB gun in a Chevy Cruze out of
all that things are looking up now it's
just sitting in Queens you got to watch
if they bring that alternate side
parking back you're [ __ ] [ __ ] take
it if they take it I got a box of eagle
eyes in the back actually you're you
know what the unfuckin uh on Monday
during Memorial Day my niece and nephew
were over and I was trying to find the
BB gun and my mom I think I rid of it I
was in the garage yelling where's the BB
gun and there was some disputes after
that if you show a little kid a BB gun
that's like the [ __ ] it you know I'm
trying to be the coolest [ __ ] guy
yeah yeah growing up would your dad ever
continue driving just to listen to the
rest of the song I would say definitely
my dad my dad was a big Motown guy
that's really all he listens to to this
day is Motown listens to the same
[ __ ] 12 songs
that's classy smooth yeah he's a big
Motown guy so my girl was playing he'd
taken her lap around the neighborhood
and undoubtedly undoubtedly hears it
Phil had some good he would always uh
he'd always turned this oh like let's
say I wanted to go like rent a video
game or go to McDonald's or something
he would always turn the turn signal on
like he was gonna go that way and then
not go that way
he also my family would do this this is
this is kind of trashy now looking back
after church after church which
sometimes me and my dad would drop my
sisters and mom off at church and say we
were gonna park the car and just go get
a car wash and love their church but he
they would get they would take me out of
the car and I would have to race the car
from the top of the neighborhood to my
house they would go you know they would
tell me that I was fast enough to beat
the car and I would literally I would
trip on the curb every every single time
I would fall off the curb and my family
would drive slowly next to me just
waiting for me to fall and that was
every Sunday and I never stopped my
son's a [ __ ] idiot look at him okay I
think I only have one or two more I
think two more have you ever been to a
strip club with a family member I don't
think so okay no that's always that's
always that always crosses a weird line
and a family well yeah especially it
would just be obviously would be a
cousin it'd be weird if I went with my
sister's saw them there then either one
of your parents smoked no my dad dipped
okay uh no but you smoked right I'll
smoke cigarettes so I'm not dipping hey
you can't dip it the [ __ ] comedy
clubs people get very upset yeah
economics and now it's definitely a bad
look I gotta change my ways stay away
from that I keep the sheet Sabbath
camo in the closet for a little while
you need some salmon polo shirts buddy
true do you ever light a cigarette with
a grill lighter uh for sure absolutely I
did that this weekend garbage I did that
this weekend hold up you wanna be like
garbage I did that off this weekend on a
beach cruiser on [ __ ] surf Avenue in
North Milan New Jersey who you doubt the
beach with my family has a house of when
this can happen me and my lady just came
down here I've been down here for oh
nice it's chilling do the ladies with
you yeah the German yeah we got married
oh [ __ ] I got married in February then
this all happened yeah is the German gay
now she's staying in America she's here
baby I'm a patriot oh my god I brought
over that dirty Germany I feel like
Shane's about to report Frank shows up I
got one of them this is it for me dude
did you or anybody in your family I'm
assuming extended family for the word
wash do they say wash wash yes 100% the
lady that makes the ham the lady that my
anthem makes the ham salad absolutely
says wash your hands before you make the
ham say help it worse yeah yeah there's
some people in my family that have that
[ __ ] like Western Central PA [ __ ]
accent yeah it's almost like a Chicago
accent in some parts it definitely
becomes Midwest like as soon as you
leave Philly it starts to transform it
in the Midwest like Pittsburgh is as far
as the you know the people it's a
Midwest City yeah a hundred percent sure
sure a [ __ ] yen skating downtown
Randy Greenberg was just on from girls
oh nice and she had a she said yen's I
was like that's disgusting oh really is
using John I
I just I can't stop saying alls that's a
very
I don't know what the [ __ ] that is but
like all you have to do there alls all
you gotta do oh yeah yeah down here I've
heard a couple of times
Everywhere's like I looked everywhere is
I can't find it anywhere
Jesus Christ yeah I can't this Central
PA accent I have is it comes out a
little when I say like home and [ __ ]
like that but uh I also do this thing
where I like I'll ask a question that's
just a sentence and it's obvious that
someone's like if someone's walking
outside a big going outside I can't I
can't stop doing it that's the only
thing that's yeah it's trashy many well
that's you can't get away plus being
back at the house the trash tendencies
come out oh yeah yeah if I'm in
mechanics for too long dude I am Trump
2020 Oh Phil Phil watches Fox News I was
joking about it on my own Matt change
secret podcast uh but uh Fox News I
realized is just like white dudes
respond to Fox News the same way like
black ladies at church too like my dad
just sits there
Fox News is black church for white guys
like he was sir Tucker Carlson he'll say
something to my dad a bag mm-hmm like he
oughta bleary ax to the television the
whole time the whole time Uzi it's like
a dog watch seeing dogs on television
like that's how dads react to fox news
like some look they'll see Obama wears
that Kenyan Muslim [ __ ]
have you ever anybody in your family
ever towed your own car when you're in a
car towing a car or it could be one of
the really small you all's that you
hooked up just the two front it's an
ugly you put the two front tires on it
god I don't think I don't think we've
done that I mean I'm sure my cousins
have but no not in my direct family now
I'm sure Frank has Frank he's done yeah
I think he drives a truck
no one else is really trashy - if you
ever push a car with your car like put
it in neutral like on that have you guys
ever had to pop a car where it's a stick
and it won't start and you keep it in
neutral and then you push it and pop it
in the gear to get to school that's they
got rid of manual transmissions in the
90s they're the best man of the [ __ ]
ambassador so fun to drive last question
Shane Gillis are you garbage do you guys
put up trains at Christmas we had a
train sets we had a train set it was
never really put together I tried to put
it together every year cuz I was a big
fan of it it said Santa Fe on the side
of it I remember yeah the Santa Fe was
it silver and red it was it was amazing
and no we never really got to it but it
did stay in the house for about 20 years
looks very intact in fact I bet I could
go in that back room in this basement
and for real find it I have I have 120
feet away from me hanging on the wall
that's awesome
my there's a shelf in here that has 30
Hess trucks on it no Reese trucks are
garbage my my grandma oh my god [ __ ]
choke yeah would buy me Hess trucks
every year for my birthday actually she
just died and last s truck I got I got
30 Hess trucks I never know one of my
family ever did Hess trucks I didn't
know anything about it I guess I missed
all the commercials as a kid I went over
my buddy's house when we were like 12
and he had Hesh trucks I'm like what
wait hold on you there's like a my
[ __ ] loves them especially the later
ones he's lit up they lit good they
stopped let me take him out they stopped
let me take it they my parents thought
it was like a currency is real garbage I
was getting the Horrocks
I was gonna inherit the mint-condition
Hess trucks when I got older and I hate
him they literally were trying to say
like let's say I sold 30 Hess trucks to
somebody how much do you think that
would be worth 18 bucks
[Music]
Chang Gillis are you garbage baby
he's trying this for the listener there
is a Penn State a framed Penn State
picture I believe behind Notre Dame
stopping Penn State because like I said
earlier there is a well at least there
was a pretty staunch anti-catholic and
you know so viewer if you hated
Catholics you really like to Penn State
and obviously you're Catholic you loved
so that rivalry was still huge here for
no reason like everybody hates Notre
Dame or hates Penn State for sure
and what's the metal that's hanging off
of it all right these are my dad's girls
high school state championships that he
is a volunteer coach for and I feel like
an [ __ ] buddy I taught that did I was
trying to get those intros right I
[ __ ] forgot Matt and Shane secret
broadcast [ __ ] [ __ ] don't feel bad
about it I'm sorry Matt Shane secret
podcast Shane Gillis is there anything
else you want the other folks to know no
[Laughter]
I know
sorry I sucked about I also never wanted
to I hate zooming in on by hate zoom
podcasts I guess but whatever this whole
thing has been on my head because I feel
like I'm stepping on everybody because
of the connection I feel like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that people [ __ ] for it it's
tough
[ __ ] them I can't wait till it's over
when we get back into the [ __ ] studio
we definitely want to have you back
- gosh and Gilles everybody buddy thank
you we'll let you go appreciate your
time hi boys
thanks bro later now we want to move in
to the to the squad all right to the
patreon fans we want to thank everybody
that signed up so far we really really
appreciate it
as you guys know if you want to have a
question sign up for the patreon you're
gonna get a lot of bonus content and
we're gonna get to read one of your
questions we got a few of them right now
that we want to go through Kippy has
them in a sealed envelope and we're
gonna find out what we got what do you
got Kip yeah so guys when you join the
patreon I mean we're we're getting
hundreds of questions at this point it's
kind of impossible to get to all of them
so kind of one of the perks of joining
the patreon as we will automatically
read one of your questions on an episode
and that brings us to now
PricewaterhouseCoopers was just at my
front door dropped off the envelope with
all the [ __ ] questions that big man
showed up they cross your T's and dotted
their eyes let's get to it by the way we
got some [ __ ] funny ass listeners
also some [ __ ] real [ __ ] garbage
some of these kids are asking questions
doesn't the four where did you grow up a
[ __ ] trailer and Mississippi goddamn
buddy gonna get a glove getting a city
will you alright this one is from a
patreon member Chris James it's have you
ever done donuts in an empty wet parking
lot donuts on people's front lawns let
me take it back to the fall of 94 I was
sipping around [ __ ] Bluebell and I
[ __ ] 1989 Nissan se v6 pickup truck I
thought I was Michael J Fox at the end
of back to the future just a [ __ ]
douche bag zipping around and I
specifically remember we went to some
party at some kids house who went to
another school
he kicked this out and I'm gonna lay out
the door I [ __ ] drove the truck
across his parents lawn and [ __ ]
turfed it and kept it moving
did your aunt Maggio he heard every
[ __ ] door from a high school movie
ever see her [ __ ] letterman jacket
on Later Mahoney I'm [ __ ] turf your
lawn dude it's [ __ ] dork I made with
it and then I made out with his mom and
kept it [ __ ] movin I know you and
your dirtbag friends [ __ ] went into a
parking lot on a rainy night no my car I
had a [ __ ] 95 Chevy lumina with the
paint chipping off I couldn't ever
[ __ ] get it and I couldn't get it
cooking this is art do it to start doing
donuts I did do some wide circles though
couple of figure eights I was doing
you'd snap a CV joint in two seconds
dude I was [ __ ] I had a big auto
grandfather car was my first car and
crashed it like ten times
donuts in an empty parking lot garbage
yeah something at some point in my life
I thought that was cool I'd look at
somebody doing donuts like I probably
get some [ __ ] tail like a [ __ ]
stunt car driver they get out of the car
with the helmet on with all due respect
Lucius i'ma do some driving they crawl
out through the window okay this is from
patreon member Nathan growler have you
ever worn jeans in the pool dude if
you're wearing denim on a beach or in a
pool
you're [ __ ] trash wait does he mean a
full pair of jeans or like cut-offs it
just says cuz I've been everywhere in a
pair a cutoff something I've been to
funerals and cut-offs it was the 80s
maybe wear cut-offs were a set of daisy
dukes was welcome wherever you go oh my
god
I remember one kid dude I was I was a
camp counselor at a and we went away to
like Six Flags or something for the day
we took all the kids and this kid wore
jeans and then he wanted to wear jeans
and the [ __ ] wave fool and I was a
dude every bone in my body will not let
you get in those get in the [ __ ] way
pull in a set of dungarees it ain't
happening at least take your cigarettes
out of your pocket but you gotta get
back to work kid my nephew my nephew
today he was swimming at the house and
he jumped into the pool with his t-shirt
on I was all over that I was like no no
no get that [ __ ] t-shirt off he's
like but I take it I'm like well we're
fat family all right we let our titties
and we let our manboobs hang in the pool
okay we're a skins team shirts and skins
okay
this is a from Matt D Matt D crusty
did you ever reuse plastic we're like
knives forks and cops I feel like that
that might be a thing you guys did today
yesterday memorial putting [ __ ] Solo
cups in the dishwasher my god that's so
low like like it's the second tier of
that's how you know you're trash when
you [ __ ] rate that the [ __ ] the
gauge of your plastic plates supply we
go to pot dude that's [ __ ] I went
over my remember to shout out to flip
who is I wonder my buddy flips house at
one time and his grand mom was like
washing out Solo cups and was like she
tried to pour me a [ __ ] Pepsi or
something that water in the bottom I'm
duds
I'll take it can from the garage fridge
and keep it [ __ ] movin you could
taste the Palmolive I said yeah using a
dirty sponge to clean out a one time you
solo cup let's go give me a give me a
chilled glass like I'm walking like a
gentleman that's we got to put that down
as a question Jared frosted mugs in the
freezer
I was drinking some runs of frosted mugs
a couple of weeks ago all right this is
from our girl court shot at the court or
have you ever put shredded or sliced
cheese on plain macaroni to make mac and
cheese
yes I've recently during the pandemic I
took you know that we were heavily
invested in crowny and cheese shout-out
to the good people of Kraft but the
night before we had taco night so I had
some mild cheddar in the in the fridge
there's nothing mild about you okay I
put that in the macaroni and cheese
it really classes it up I'm not gonna
lie you have a nice bottle of Pinot Noir
oh you got a nice night
nice bag of Pinot Noir yeah I've
definitely done it as a fact in my you
know super fat kid days [ __ ] some
penne pasta with some broken up Kraft
singles throw it in the microwave for a
couple of minutes gooey goodness that's
what that is
you ever eat the shredded cheese out of
the bag like a [ __ ] animal today you
did dude every time you if you if you're
putting shredded cheese on on something
you gotta take you gotta go right to the
[ __ ] source
you know those for the doctor butters
you never ever ever get all the shreds
in your mouth wow that's like the crane
game you go in there with a pins you go
in there with your fingers pull it up by
the time it gets out it's all over the
floor it's all over your shirt yeah
you're rolling the dice in a clean
kitchen you pull that [ __ ] move
yeah man all right I think you fall
under this next category this is from
our boy Power Ranger talk have you ever
traveled with a plastic bag as part of
your luggage yes yeah I don't know if I
haven't I'm I'm a you know I'm more of a
gentleman you know more of a roller bag
kind of guy
I'm very loose when it comes to the term
on delivery carry on carry on can mean a
lot of things
no it means one thing it means a duffle
bag or the [ __ ] backpack which goes
under your legs or the little scooter
John or the little roller boy but I'm a
big tote guy kippy I like to I like to
put my stuff in a tote I've used the
tote as a carry-on that's just because
you don't have actual [ __ ] luggage
that's why you use tote bags yeah I know
what happens we were gonna have to play
my flip-flop fell out fell on the floor
and I held the line up took out a small
Asian family with that with that [ __ ]
boat
low bridge all right
bend over and pick up a bunch of [ __ ]
out of my tote that fell people were
waiting by me like this fat [ __ ] yeah I
would hate to be next to you on a plane
um okay this is from the AL bot
have you ever faked an injury to get on
a roller coaster or a plane faster no
but I'm a big fan of pretending that I'm
sick so I can get out of doing a lot of
things get to the end of the drive
through I'm a veteran bring it up I'm
sick update that's a pretty good one man
have you ever done that I think you have
I have I think we pulled some like
anxiety yeah well we did a Norfolk I
know we did it at Disney see that move
at Disney's get a fast pass so you can
zoom around a little quicker but the
ones you can't get a fast pass on you
pull the old I got [ __ ] anxiety
business you get right to the front of
the line of the [ __ ] fires and the
Caribbean too sweet I'll pay that much I
got a 12 year old back here with pts
kids got a weak heart
let's go he walked in on he's [ __ ]
slapping my monkey one time he hasn't
been the same since get him on the
teacups man yeah we've done that have
you all right this is from prints at
Suzuki I'm gonna butcher that prints at
uzuki and have you ever been threatened
or assigned court-ordered counseling
this one's a little [ __ ] dicey no but
I in 11th grade my girlfriend was over
at her friend's house and there was a
bunch of kids that were like freshmen in
college but she was friends with and it
was a bunch of them there and I called
over there to talk to her and some dude
picked the phone up my gauge in there
means I guess she suck on my dick right
now and he didn't realize he was dealing
I [ __ ] lunatic so I hopped in my
[ __ ] truck and went over there and
was banging on the door with it with a
knife in my hand and before anybody came
out one of my buddies mom showed up and
they took me straight to Norristown
state hospital for evaluation what were
you gonna do
Oh yummy we got a new [ __ ] butter so
you gotta need room room temperature
butter in there that I can spread easily
Chelsea says it's okay yeah my boy
Sheldon says it's alright you know
what's great about him just to say like
he he can take apart an argument so well
yeah like that is such a good point like
just to think that poor people think
that everything's gonna go bad so they
keep it in the fridge
rich people classy people keep it out I
don't know I'm still on the fence a
little bit about it but I mean I think
some points that's probably his Scottish
roots I bet his mom did that whatever
there was butter in the house sure okay
moving on ah this is from Jeff Jeff have
you ever taken money at taking money
from a wishing well or like one of those
wishing palms now but I got busted when
I was like maybe 10 years old you know
they have those things at like
drugstores where you put a quarter in
it's it's it's for like some charity
it's like it looks like an advent
calendar and you mind it yeah it's like
st. Jude's or something yeah you put a
quarter in like a little slot but it's
all presented there you were stealing
the quarters I stole all of them and my
mom caught me walking out the door and I
had to go back and get into the
pharmacists and all this [ __ ] was all
big thing that in the perk the per 30
you had hey sorry about the quarters and
these school buses I got my pocket buddy
he's mister don't take all my xanies
leave some for me oh god you're garbage
I did that one time shot or not one time
I think I've done it a couple of I would
always throw it back in it would be more
like I needed you know I wanted more
[ __ ] action you know what I mean I
wouldn't [ __ ] take it and put it in
my talk if you're walking around what
pockets like it's your fault but I would
take it and just like throw it back in
or whatever but shots in a shammy mall
they had a mean [ __ ] mall big rocks
around it I think you could stop that
question is have you ever stuck your
hand in a wishing fountain because those
things are disgusting oh that like weird
there was always like cookies in the
bottom of it or you know somebody throw
a lollipop in there there's a weird
slime on the floor yeah I don't think
those things are around that much
anymore
um this one's pretty funny uh this is
from pea patreon Charlie Frank have you
ever have you or a family member ever
worn a motor sports brand either our
Tcat or Fox Racing jacket as their
primary winter coat ever see some dude
walking through like [ __ ] Target that
looks like he parked a snowmobile out
front buddy get a car what are you doing
go to it go to [ __ ] ancien I'm gonna
get a coat like a [ __ ] gentlemen I
always said things that were motorcycle
jackets when they weren't riding a
motorcycle was gardening some dude with
a shoe jacket on
I'd be like me walking around with a
jacket that says I'm a comedian you know
what I mean
like you just want you want to show what
you are when you're not on the bike I
walking around a scuba suit on hey
summer in Aruba that's pretty funny
I definitely like a fox racing t-shirt
and I've never been on a [ __ ] dirt
bike or anything
all right this from patreon Eliot Jay
have you or a family member ever
purchased anything from QVC or the Home
Shopping Network
I got a hunch that you're garbage mom
spends most of her day posted up with a
couple of more bros and the phone ready
let me tell you something back in the
early 90s okay there was a mad rush on
several items that you could only get
through QVC or the Home Shopping Network
and my aunt's and my mom would like take
turns like so like they were calling in
a radio station for [ __ ] Bon Jovi
tickets to try to get a couple one of
them was the electric ashtray you know
what that was it was it sucked it had
like an exhaust fan on it on it that
just blew back out into the air it did
yeah just blew it out the side instead
of the top your family is we've routed
garbage you your family hatch like a
Ponzi scheme to get something to smoke
more cigarettes in the house where
nobody was using that thing outside
nothing in the house smoking apparatus
mm-hmm man that's [ __ ] try a that's
one thing we never my mom never that was
always beautiful Ike scams you know what
I mean like anything you see on TV this
game oh we ordered tons
like that Ginsu knives [ __ ] all that
stuff are you thinking sir knives was
made by like a Jewish dude in Long
Island that was know like there was no
like samurai who came up with that I
think we even had a chopper what was
that thing with it turns around or
whatever it was so strong
yeah people started they started you
know those things became widely accepted
pampered chef I think made a couple of
them shout-out to PC this one i'ma [ __ ]
my mom dude we used to this we used to
make a day out of this have you ever
repurposed old t-shirts as a rag oh dude
that's all through the 90s my mom would
just like t-shirts are getting cut up
and we would just cut them up and use
them I remember that time that [ __ ] cut
up my GI Joe shirt I used to [ __ ]
love that thing dude you're cleaning the
[ __ ] toilet with that I know my
[ __ ] GI Joe shirt that's funny dude
that brings back some [ __ ] memories
you know what's garbage too though
everybody has it that makes me think of
it I was trying to figure out a question
that they had asked that but like when
old clothes become like cleaning clothes
or paint clothes yeah that one pair of
jeans that has paint on it that you
always had to wear if you were doing
[ __ ] like that
my mom has like three outfits like that
yeah you know what you should see when
she wears to work in the bedroom nurses
uniforms gym graduate high school I came
from I don't know if that degrees on the
[ __ ] on the on the up and up but let
me I love a bedpan extraction I forget I
was gonna say oh they've grown up
especially in the suburbs was if you had
you the set of grass cutting shoes that
were just all green oh dude you gotta
put those things on every week that
[ __ ] stunk every dad when he would
have to cut the lawn in the [ __ ] 80s
and 90s looks like a goober it had a
white a pear that was originally white
pair of New Balances that were now green
you know it's really trashy that was a
big dad move
was the the short-sleeved sweatshirt no
that was big and I was a big eighties
thing yeah yeah and it was always cut
like too high up on the by saram that on
the on the yeah the bicep yeah that's
how out of shape you are
what's the arm one what's the one on the
arm but that's a dinosaur go ahead the
Triceratops oh my god your fat end um um
alright just a couple more we'll get to
the rest later this is from Jeff my
family never did this have you ever kept
the grease from bacon or pork chops in a
coffee can to cook with later no but my
best friend girl on a broad decline who
was african-american his mom did that
and dude she was good eating it's
[ __ ] great eatin I know my dad might
my grandmother when I was a kid my dad
tells me is that his mom would make
bacon in a cast-iron skillet and then
take the bacon out and then use that
grease to make the eggs that's what
that's I think if you're reusing it
right away yeah sure I mean saving it to
like use it a later date than they Islam
that grease can that some of my friend's
house has smelled so bad shots of it
like it was cutting yeah - bacon grease
in a tallboy snap I'll tell you the
whole story all right and the last one
for this week this is from our boy Louis
M and I think this is an O for both of
us did your mom ever pick up smokes for
you before you could drive no yeah but
before I could buy cigarettes really
that's trashy I think so yeah your mom's
mind you packs a Bernese before you
could [ __ ] in before you even legally
love to smoke dude that's crazy I don't
care I don't care if your dad's a doctor
anything you are [ __ ] if you're buying
your underage kid Bernie's your trash I
never did it
I still hide it from my mom from time to
time when I go out and dabble it a nice
Bernie you know
his mom obviously did so the question
came from oh for sure for dude I had
buddies I think I talked about it on one
of these episodes buddy would get like a
carton of Newports and a pack of condoms
in his Christmas in his in his stocking
I'm like damn talk about a stocking
stuffer shoes horn shootin porno videos
over talking garbage yeah guys that's it
for this week thank you so much those
are all patreon members that signed up
in the last two days we just launched it
so thank you so much
also if you want to you can go to
patreon.com/scishow so description
everything like that and you can get
free you get a bonus episode every week
you can get something from the hard
feelings archive which is another
podcast me and Foley's that we're really
similar those every week we're also
gonna be doing live streams as well so
you can get all of that exclusive
content at patreon.com slash are you
garbage and when you sign up we will
read your question on the yes sir a lot
of big things coming up we want all you
guys to get locked in on the patreon
we're gonna have a lot of great things
in there a lot of exclusive content
alright guys thanks so much we
appreciate it check us out full full
video available on YouTube please rate
review subscribe on iTunes also I am
Kevin at Kevin Ryan comedy on all social
media and I am @h Foley on ice on
Twitter and Foley Graham's on Instagram
make sure you follow us are you garbage
on Instagram and follow you are you're
garbage on Twitter again we appreciate
you guys we love you guys
and we'll see you next time thank you